[Music]
hey y'all
jenny's got that nice intro
you know if i do say so myself i really
like the little microwave thing at the
end
[Laughter]
well yeah there was like i found uh i
found a whole bunch of videos of
one person that makes videos that puts
them on a free site and they just like
had all these ones of different foods
spinning around
yeah i was like that's cool i'm gonna
use all of those all right so we got
some of our regulars in there
um waiting for me to talk about food
yeah we're doing food today
this is uh this is a good topic all
right and i'm just gonna start
to give you guys a heads up and just a
primer on
some [ __ ] that the average person
probably doesn't think about
especially in a time like this all right
where there might be
power problems food problems hurricanes
any kind of natural disasters riots
doesn't i don't know where you live okay
it could be anywhere
um how do you eat you know
if you don't have any power [ __ ] it's a
nightmare
because everything in your refrigerator
was gonna go bad so you have to eat all
that first
yep gotta eat all that ice cream yeah i
don't think we have any ice cream so
you gotta have some kind of a way to
eat food keep certain things cold
and be able to you have to have
ingredients that can survive
without being uh refrigerated
well imagine if you try to make bread
all right and you don't have a
refrigerator it's [ __ ] tough
all right so like for instance the milk
and the eggs and the butter all right
so that'll be bad
so you have to [ __ ] look at other
things one of the main things
that i keep around the house is this
anybody from latin america will know
what this is neato
this is uh powdered milk yeah
you can get it from walmart and it comes
in two
kinds this is the regular and then
there's another one that you can use
for babies that's rated for you know
bottles
but with this you can complete
a recipe if you don't have milk
i use it for that and you can also
use it to make things that you may not
have on hand like if a recipe calls for
cream
you could just use this with a couple
teaspoons of cold water
and make milk or make cream then you can
thin it out and make milk
or if you're if you need coffee creamer
this will work
if you want to cream up a gravy or some
kind of a stock it's in a pan
cooking and uh you don't want to open up
your milk and you use your liquid milk
you can get you can get a teaspoon of
this
and put it in there it's just a handy
thing
that um i picked up in living in brazil
you know in brazil most people will you
know if you live especially if you're
living in a favela this is your milk
it's just dried the quality of it has
gotten
pretty good nowadays it's it's good
now if you were in a um let's say you
were in a
hurricane situation you know the
hurricane's coming so you're gonna have
ice chests and in the bottom of the ice
chest a bunch of melted water
and it's cold you can pop the drain
and drain some of that water out of the
bottom of that ice chest
right into your brita water filter and
filter it
and then add this to it and make make
cold milk out of it
so that's this is this there you go yes
this is a real important thing i have to
say too that i either use that or
i use the coffee creamer because
sometimes if i want some like [ __ ] uh
hot chocolate or something and it's like
i don't really want to
make it with milk or whatever so usually
i just kind of like because we have one
of those
uh pitchers everybody in europe has one
but not that many people in the u.s have
them where the pitcher you just put
water and it just like heats it up you
know boils it
yeah so i usually just put like two
scoops of
coffee creamer or that and one scoop of
quick
and then pour boiling water on it and
voila yeah
delicious there's a lot of recipes where
you can use this
in it's um the nutrition on it's very
good a lot better than say
coffee creamer coffee creamer has no
nutrition in it it's very high in
protein very high in fat
very low in carbohydrate and it's good
high in calories so
uh in a survival situation this will
help you
okay now another one that's good to have
is this powdered eggs
yeah all right they just come in handy
you can make um
dough with it cookies bread you can just
make the eggs themselves make a big old
omelette in a pan
put the ingredients inside the glass pan
and cook it
and then you say well if you don't have
power how are you going to cook it well
you should have a gas grill
if you got a lid on a gas grill you can
put the fire down pretty low
cover the lid just put your glass pan
right there on top of the grill
it'll cook but yeah whole eggs
very very important in a survival
hurricane type situation and once again
72 servings in this that's a lot of eggs
okay um there's a lot of fat a lot of
protein
cholesterol is pretty high but it's the
nutrition's good well eggs have a lot of
cholesterol yeah
but it's not bad cholesterol eggs or
eggs are actually really good for you
yeah and if you're in a emergency
situation
hurricanes and you know [ __ ] just
survival or whatever you need that
cholesterol that's gonna all that'll
help you
i don't think i've ever had those just
plain i've had things
like made with those with powdered eggs
but i don't think i've ever
maybe i did when i was younger i don't
think i've ever like actually made
like an omelette or something with
powdered eggs yeah
it's good yeah yeah you can't really
tell the difference
oh yeah you can yeah yeah yeah
it doesn't it doesn't taste as good as
uh you know natural eggs
but at least it was eggs yeah yeah i
mean man i love it
at least you ate something yeah now
here's something else
butter flavored crisco it's cheap
and it's an excellent butter substitute
it's got little cookies on
it makes great cookies i actually like i
like the crisco and cookies better than
the uh
better than butter there's some about
vegetable shortening it's it just gives
a different texture yeah
flavor because i feel like growing up um
when my mom made cookies or baked goods
she almost always use
shortening shortening like nowadays it
seems like most people just use like oil
or butter or something like that but i
don't know like the shortening was just
i don't know the [ __ ] tasted better
yeah and vegetable shortening got got
the united states through the great
depression
you could do a lot with this man you
know you can make a lot
biscuits bread cookies
yeah it was what they used to use lard
for it but
this was a lot better yeah it was a
little i don't know if it was better for
you but it's cheaper it's probably
better for you
i think it i think yeah it's probably
better for i don't know if it tastes as
good as lard
well no that's [ __ ] great didn't they
now i don't know if this is true or not
but didn't they used to make that way a
long time ago
when oreos first came out wasn't the
middle of oreos used to be lard and
sugar
yeah i thought it was yeah i think it is
they don't make it with artists it's
just
it's just shortening now i think yeah i
think it's shortening now but
the lard would be even better well
obviously
[Laughter]
and then the the fourth thing i don't
have it here with me because you know
what it looks like that's just
the flower flower by the bags you can
get a big
bag of flour for 10 15 bucks and make a
lot of loaves of bread
and there's a lot of different kinds of
bread out there the indian naan
doesn't require much it's just yogurt
water i don't even think there's any
yeast in it
and flour so i think any of those kind
of like naan or
pita or anything like that those are
unleavened right they're on the left
yeah so i don't
just make the dough i've made it before
and it just i don't think there was
there was no yeast in it
it was just water yogurt
i think there was a little bit of lemon
or something in there and then you put
it inside of uh
all-purpose flour and spread it out into
a into a little piece of dough and you
can put it on
any kind of hot surface and it'll turn
into non you want a hot stone like for
pizza stone to be the best
which you can put that in your gas grill
put the pizza stone in the gas grill get
it real hot
throw it throw it on it'd be just like a
town door oven we've made pizza um on
the grill
a couple of times yeah on a pizza stone
on the pizza stone you put the pizza
stove
on the grill it's good it is really good
yeah it's really good
that if you get it hot enough you can
get it above 550 degrees
yeah i thought because the gas grill
gets hotter than that
and it'll cook quickly and it'll make a
perfect crust if it's as long as you
uh had delayed fermentation going on
inside that dough
so powdered eggs good quality powdered
eggs you can get them online
good quality powdered milk i prefer
neato
all right if you have children or babies
there's a special needle it's a little
bit more expensive it's rated for
infants
okay then you want to get crisco the
buttered flavor actually is like the
deluxe version
yeah they have at um
they have at um best value you know at
the what is it
sam no it's sam's no no no walmart at
walmart i think derek brand is called
best value
yeah or great value great value
something like that they sell a great
value
plain one about this big for like a
dollar or something
yeah so making some cookies and [ __ ]
with that yeah
you could live a long time off of this
out of a bunch of these
and a big old bags of flour and
some yeast and maybe a little bit of
sugar you can sit there and make bread
all day long
and just putting next to nothing on a
piece of bread is a lot more satisfying
than just you know what i mean
having no bread at all yeah bread is a
like
carbs are like more filling obviously so
it's just kind of like
you know i don't know it's just kind of
like the difference between having a
salad or having like some vegetables
over some pasta or something
yeah you can make a broth and thicken
broth with a little bit of flour and you
know
use salt and then make some kind of a
stew and then just you know
sop it up with bread i mean that's what
peasants did in the middle ages they
mostly lived off of bread and things
that were like bread bread and beer
honestly i kind of feel like the whole
like i love soup
but the only reason to have soup is so
you can have like a really nice piece of
chunky bread like to dip
in it yeah you know what i mean that's
like the best thing about seed
no matter what kind it is let me check
them let me check the uh
conversation i want to say too that um
and we i think we brought this up a
little bit before
but we have like a lot of canned
vegetables and [ __ ] like that and like
we don't
use them day to day because we usually
get fresh ones
but every now and then like i said when
we're kind of um
you know rotating out the [ __ ] that's in
the pantry
i think the one time i the favorite
thing that we made out of all the
you know hey the cans are about to
expire and we need new ones
we made like a somebody made like a big
chicken pot pie right and we put like
all the different vegetables in there i
think we had some canned chicken we had
some canned
potatoes canned green beans
carrots maybe but it's just we went
through there and we were just kind of
like oh look at all this canned [ __ ] we
have in here and then we ended up making
like a really good
chicken pot pie with it and that uh
it was still good i mean you would never
know those were like canned vegetables
yeah louis says man every mexican kid
from grew up drinking dido
yeah yeah it's the same it was the same
in brazil you know brazil had
had a lot of powdered milk um
you know i mean because a lot of how
some a lot of households in brazil
didn't have power or refrigeration
yeah that's how you had to do it okay um
it's nutritious and it's readily
available
and you can use it in a wide variety of
recipes
and it just comes in handy too just
having some of that
in the cupboard next to the right there
you know where you normally cook
instead of pulling out some milk you
just now to save the milk
for drinking you know use up all your
milk for them
to make a recipe when you can make milk
you know what i mean if you if you give
me a choice between drinking neato and
drinking
something out of a carton i'm gonna
drink something out of a carton yeah
you know but yeah you want that for like
pouring on your cereal
yeah but
i'm not turning a nose up at nito if you
were hungry
you know what i mean in a
survival type situation ice cold neato
would be delicious you know what i mean
yeah it would just be delicious
if you were hungry yeah hell yeah you
would be like a godsend
it's good quality you know it doesn't
taste bad it just you can tell
it's not quite yeah it's never it never
tastes exactly the same
because it's not exactly the same i used
i don't know if they make this anymore
but at least in the u.s like a long time
ago
they used to make like a liquid milk
that was shelf stable
parmelat yeah um because i used to get
that sometimes i didn't like to drink it
by itself
because you could kind of taste that it
didn't taste quite the same but if you
put it in cereal or
you know used in recipes you couldn't
tell the difference brazil had that too
the downside of that is it's not as
concentrated
that yeah that's what i'm talking about
that that can right there [ __ ] mix
gallons and gallons and it weighs a
fraction
of what gallons and gallons it's super
cheap and it doesn't take up that much
room yeah if you had to you could throw
that in a dim
bug out bag and throw all that [ __ ] in
the trunk your car and [ __ ] get the
[ __ ] out of dodge
which some people oh you're overreacting
no not in florida
if a [ __ ] monster hurricane is coming
and you're gonna be home
like i'm getting the [ __ ] out of here
yeah yeah well because sometimes i mean
thankfully for hurricanes we usually
have a lot of warning a lot of warning
right
um although they never know exactly
where it's gonna go but they're just
always kind of like well maybe you
people
might wanna you know it might not hit
but you know just in case i'm more
worried about like [ __ ] tornadoes for
some reason
which hurricanes usually bring in their
wake i just
i don't even know how i ended up seeing
this but i um i saw a video the other
day of people in
goddamn it must be in oklahoma or
something like that or maybe texas
and it was a couple years back and this
[ __ ] uh tornado
just like tore through their [ __ ]
town and
somebody was in a store
with a bunch of other people and they
recorded the whole [ __ ] like on their
phone like everybody in the in the store
was okay
because they all were like holy [ __ ]
they saw it coming and they all ran and
hid
like in the storeroom but then they came
out and like just the whole town was
[ __ ] leveled
it was the [ __ ] freakiest thing ever
and just like the sound of it was
horrifying and like everyone's screaming
and [ __ ]
and it's you know so mango badgers
talking about
stork margarine all right yeah yeah
we have margarine too crisco is not
margarine there's a big difference
yeah it's like lard but it's made with
yeah vegetable shortening instead of
animal fat
yeah it's very heavy very dense
um you can execute bread a lot better
and you know you can execute recipes a
lot better
with uh margarine excuse me with a with
crisco
versus it's shortenings vegetable
shortening yeah butter flavored
vegetable shortening or just
regular shortening they're both good i
prefer the butter flavored
the butter flavored you know i mean for
cookies and [ __ ] like that actually you
can use it in anything it's just a
more of a deluxe yeah thing
so uh no it's not margarine margarine is
better say
like on on a prepared piece of bread as
a spread
oh it's better like on a potato you know
um but you know in an emergency you
could use that crystal crisco on a
potato too
it'd be pretty good yeah butterflies
crisco yeah yeah yeah don't just put
regular grass oh that probably wouldn't
that would just taste greasy it wouldn't
taste like anything yeah
but this is what's that safe for weight
i don't
i don't have my glasses what here i put
my glasses on yeah you guys are
heavy it's several pounds just in this
thing
and the yield is high you can make a lot
with this
and this is only a dollar something
maybe two dollars
so you can stack a lot of these in a
damn [ __ ] cupboard
all right you could carry a lot of these
you could carry one of these in a
rucksack and you would feed a whole
party of people for a week
two to three weeks maybe yeah what you
were doing louie asked if we got
earthquakes in florida
no i don't think i've ever i mean
i think there's been a couple but not
that anyone would even really notice it
i don't worry too much about the
hurricane actually what i worry about is
the repercussions of the hurricanes
okay because i went i lived through
katrina and i was in i was in louisiana
at the time what killed everybody
wasn't so much the flooding that killed
a lot of people but they were mostly
like people in convalescent homes that
couldn't swim they were just abandoned
in there
and they just drowned okay the [ __ ] was
like out of something out of the walking
dead
what killed everybody was a loss of
power
if if a highly dense popu
population area like new orleans goes
without power
for three days [ __ ] that's it man
it's over it goes mad max when people
miss
nine meals they start killing other
people to get food
and there was lots of lots and lots of
murders
there's tens of thousands of people
still missing they're dead
okay tens and ten ten many many
many thousands of cases of rape
it was [ __ ] bad really bad
it was totally lawless there were places
on certain streets there were just dead
dudes laying out on the streets shot up
because if they came into the [ __ ]
neighborhood they were just shot
because they were going in there to try
to loot food which i don't really
[ __ ] blame them but they'll kill you
to get your food
yeah you know but if you're hungry
you're going to do whatever you can to
feed your kids
and some neighborhoods were ready
because they kind of took it seriously
and other
other neighborhoods didn't take it
seriously or they didn't have the money
to stockpile
low-income areas they don't have money
to stockpile food
they're the first ones to crack and they
go out looking for food and they're
gonna go to the neighborhoods of having
food
and the neighborhoods that have the food
in katrina shot them up
then the cops came to try to stop it
they shot the cops up
then cops all started to defect what
happened to the cops the cops ran they
all ran
wouldn't you your family was at home you
had to take care of your family the
whole [ __ ] system was [ __ ] falling
apart
and it was really more to do with the
loss of power than anything else
that's what it did yeah well like i said
the worst i ever went through
and this might have been before you
moved here or before i met you
i think it was 2004 i want to say
that's before you came here right yeah
um yeah we had
four hurricanes in a six week
period none of them were
devastatingly horrible but just the fact
of getting smacked with one and then
like a week later there was another one
and then a week later there was another
one
so we had our power was out for
eight days and our
uh street was flooded and there was like
a tree
across it um so also also we had to boil
all the water obviously because the
sewage lines broke
so you couldn't drink the water out of
the tap yeah
uh you know but luckily we had kind of
got ready for it we didn't have a lot of
that kind of stuff but we had
you know we had [ __ ] like you know power
bars and
that kind of crap so we didn't like
starve to death you know what i mean it
just it wasn't fun
obviously because it was like [ __ ]
august or september so it was like 4
million degrees outside and it was like
yeah it's funny because like people who
are from the south
because of these natural disasters that
have happened within our lifetime
we don't depend on any kind of
government because that was never there
wasn't there for katrina it's not there
for any of these power outages it's not
there for any of these [ __ ]
it's just not there all right so you
have to protect yourself if you're gonna
wait
around for the government to put your
power back on
or to [ __ ] help cook you some [ __ ]
food or to help come and feed you
that food might be a month away
well yeah because there's going to be a
lot of people in the same boat as yep
and they're going to have to come down
there and set up [ __ ] and
and then if the area is dangerous they
won't set it up that was another problem
with katrina you had it you had you
tried they tried to get down there
to feed people but it was so dangerous
that people didn't want to go
yeah because you showed up
you'd be shot [ __ ] killed they'd take
the [ __ ] supplies from me they'd rape
the women and then just [ __ ] run away
it was [ __ ]
bad really bad if you were in that
[ __ ] astrodome i think what was
called no is it astrodome what was that
thing called
astrodome i think we call right that's
in houston superdome
the one the one that was i mean like i
said i think the astronomers
called they had a bunch of them up in
there man and that was [ __ ] living
hell just
hot 100 humidity 100 degrees fahrenheit
uh there's no plumbing so they were all
[ __ ] in buckets and
pissing everywhere and everybody got
driven out of the damn stadium they
couldn't stay there but like two days
it was [ __ ] horrible they tried to
bust people out
most of the buses were [ __ ]
underwater it was just
you know and then they sent the cops and
part later on the national guard to go
in there and collect up guns
because people were shooting each other
and uh the only people that gave up
their guns like old ladies
they gave up their guns and then later
on got all they got killed they took all
their [ __ ]
so it's just in a disaster a lot of
times if it's real bad like katrina
if i was i wasn't in ground zero i was
outside of it i wasn't i was in baton
rouge at the time
but i was helping the police in support
i was working for a company that was
supporting for the sport and the state
police
man those state policemen were coming
back and telling just [ __ ] horror
stories
and they covered a lot of it up they
covered a lot of it up
because it was just [ __ ] a national
tragedy
the national embarrassment what happened
out there a lot of that [ __ ]
uh a certain certain cops went rogue the
national guard went in there and shot
him up and killed
killed him they hid that they killed
about six cops
yeah there was a band of cops abandoned
new orleans
police department guys or they're at
least they were in those uniforms they
may not have been nopd i don't know
but they told me that they were nopd
running around raping women and stealing
[ __ ]
and the national guard [ __ ] kind of
got a kill order on them and went out
there and [ __ ] killed those dudes
they were [ __ ] heavily armed
ar-15s and [ __ ] cop cars
[ __ ] just bad [ __ ] um
dudes went rogue i guess they figured
they weren't going to survive in any way
so they just started acting a fool
i suppose so it looked like the end of
the world yeah
they just did and they did no fresh
water they were drinking filthy water a
lot of them died from sicknesses and
[ __ ] later
because they were just drinking the
water that was going through the city it
had [ __ ] motor oil in it
raw sewage yeah that's what i mean it's
like what the [ __ ] else are you going to
do
it had anything else to drink that's
what they would drink it they didn't
have any way to purify water
so i think about this kind of [ __ ] you
know what i mean [ __ ]
it wasn't that that killed most of those
people in katrina it was the
power outage yeah it's always a good
idea to have
i mean we have a gas grill we have uh
you know a pantry that's full we also
have another closet that's right
here outside of this office that also
has a bunch of food like oatmeal
[ __ ] like that yeah dry stable dry food
stuff yeah like so
what okay so other than uh you know the
shortening and the
powdered eggs and powdered milk which
are obviously really good what else
would you
advise people have in their pantries i
would say i would say like peanut butter
yeah peanut butter powder peanut butter
i got them both
another good thing is uh the um
protein shake mix the big ones like from
uh you can get them
from uh sam's or whatever that
bodybuilders use for their protein
protein drinks because if you're not
getting meat that's a great meat
substitute
you can just make neato nuts are good to
have too i think
yeah but power per pound they're
expensive
yeah but i'm saying pound per pound as a
source of protein
that whey protein muscle tech
what they call it it's chocolate vanilla
they have strawberry
you can get a big container of it
doesn't weigh much
but two scoops
with inside of a a couple cups of say
neato
even water in emergency would be about
like what a chicken breast is
in nutrition and it weighs a fraction of
what a chicken breast weighs
it's in a much smaller area doesn't
require any refrigeration
now you could almost kind of live on
that but not
you want to have the ability to make
bread out of these things
have powdered eggs uh have some
milk that you can make up you know you
want to be able to
be able to make things you know and
if you run out of propane you're going
to have to get out of hibachi
you know yeah or a small griddle or
something
and hook it up with um wood and just
and if you have to start tearing down a
[ __ ] abandoned house in an emergency
you tear down a damn abandoned house to
get the wood out of it
or just burn the furniture and cook on
that just cooking it
cut everything into small pieces and put
it inside of hibachi be efficient with
it
because if you have to do that you do
that too then put a cover over the
hibachi so you can
bake something like bread even though
the temperature won't be
you can try to stabilize the temperature
with a thermometer and add more
fuel to the fire i mean they did that in
the middle ages
you know they were cooking bread back
then too they usually just cooked it at
real high heat though
yeah high heat oh that looks good take
it out
and close enough close enough in the
middle
if you're hungry that's all you need
though it probably is okay yeah
well what i would suggest though is to
do what what they would do in india and
that's make that
non yeah i mean that seems like and we
eat that with like pretty much
everything like [ __ ] yesterday we
scrambled some eggs and some sausage and
just like wrapped it up in a piece of
naan or pita or whatever yeah cause you
don't need
you don't need a real oven to make naan
you just need a hot surface
yeah so you can have a pan over over a
fire a pan on a grill
over over you know the fire underneath
it get that pan real hot or a pizza
stone
get that stone real hot and just throw
pieces of naan on there and flip it over
it only takes a few seconds
a few minutes on each side and it's
ready so you can sit there and make
bread make a sandwich put
put a damn squirrel in the middle of it
roll it up eat him
hang him up yeah put some cinnamon and
sugar on there
roll it up if you talk about hunting
things like
squirrels and [ __ ] sparrows and [ __ ]
don't worry about a 22 just use a
[ __ ]
pump air rifle with a pellet pellet
rifle that's the best way
okay you're just wasting ammo 22 rounds
on [ __ ] squirrels
just use bbs or pellets if they're just
just
pop their little heads they'll fall out
of the tree the thing is you'll find
that to make a full meal you need about
10 squirrels just fill them in they're
very small there's not much there
but it is some protein and you just
gut him cut the head and the legs off
cut him down
you know then pull the fur off of it and
you'll have to look like a little man
looks like a little man that's a little
bitty tiny little man you can pretend
it's a little tiny man if you want to
that's insurance little little man look
at this little man
yeah you can put his [ __ ] squirrels
put a spit through it and then cook him
over a fire it doesn't take long
there's not much meat there no okay but
you could
pull the meat off the bones and put it
on a piece of bread and just you know
eat it like that
grampa's hammer says ramen noodles yeah
we got a bunch of those too yeah got a
bunch of those
probably ramen noodles is there's no
treat they're not real nutritious no
nutrition it's just good though
just filler yeah just make you like not
be hungry yeah
danny rolling ghost face says hard tack
yeah
yeah yeah no flavor no flavor no real
nutrition
uh if you do what i said get these
some get those four things with the with
the flour
and then get some muscle tech which is
uh you know
it's whey protein flavored whey protein
you can make a high
protein drink out of all that
the drink is about the nutrition is a
very similar to a chicken breast
that's pretty good that's real good if
uh you're in a survival situation
you'd only need one of them a day and
then some other filler stuff to
kind of get you through you would be
losing
weight if you were already lean and you
were trying to carry a lot of muscle
you'd start losing muscle you'd probably
want about
four cups of that a day with some filler
you know like four chicken breasts a day
but it's very
lean very lean high in protein
the flavor is good it's just not quite
not quite as filling as a piece of meat
but
you know you do what you gotta do you do
what you have to do
if you threw in some bread with that uh
you you'd feel a lot better
yeah definitely yeah gramster says i
have a couple hundred little bottles of
booze mainly to barter with but also to
make a stiff drink
you can use nine millimeter rounds in 22
rounds and five five six rounds is money
too if it ever got that bad
you could use ammunition as money but i
don't think it'll ever get
that bad particularly because you know i
growing up in uh in south america parts
of brazil were pretty much in what would
be called stage three collapse
and it was still pretty functional i was
comfortable it there
but there that it was chaos you know it
was true anarchy
there was no cops that you would
recognize as cops
it was just gangs militias
drug cartels and guys that were dressed
like cops
that were just watching their own ass
they they weren't
doing what you would call enforcing any
kind of laws they were issuing tickets
because that's that was that's their gig
that's where the money comes from
the money doesn't come from enforcing
laws it's just over in south america it
just comes from
writing tickets because uh one
that's an opportunity that the cop can
get a bribe out of you
if you pay him part of it he'll take the
cash instead of
charging a ticket so in other words a
bribe is 50 of what the ticket cost is
usually
yeah okay so he's gonna give all his
tickets he's gonna get all these bribes
all right um but he does he will write a
certain amount of tickets a day because
that's the
the stations that's the unit's cash he's
got to keep the cash flow going to the
unit
usually when you have societal collapse
no one can be trusted
everything becomes very corrupt very
quickly
everything becomes scammified because
people need these scams to survive
so the scam the skin the scammetry
increases
as civilization decreases scams increase
which you see a lot of that today it's
just starting to look a lot like brazil
but it's going to be a lot more violent
because there's
a lot more hatred and anti-american
propaganda
the propaganda is telling americans to
hate hate and kill one another basically
what it's telling them to do um
i i think it's coming from outside i
think most of it's from china
i think they got mad about that trade
war uh
and uh the institutions are pretty
rotten in the united states and there's
a lot of political divisions in the
division
political and racial divisions and
they're being maximized by
forces inside that are making profit and
forces outside that are getting [ __ ]
a a strategic leg up on it they want to
invade taiwan
russia wants to invade uh crimea and and
and ukraine so the
a civil conflict inside the united
states will help two other superpowers
so you know they're gonna
ramp that up you know i don't live in
the fantasy world where everybody's
friendly nah
everybody's out to get you that's closer
to the truth
and uh knocking america out of the world
system would [ __ ]
most of the world would really like that
because uh the us has [ __ ] abused a
lot of countries over the years if you
go back to the 1800s and everything
what they did in central and south
america during the banana wars and most
people don't even know
what that is
that new york new york banksters [ __ ]
collapsed
dozens of central american and south
american
elected republics just to [ __ ]
reduce the cost of bananas and to get
involved in the banana [ __ ] trade
and it's not really part of u.s history
we don't even know it i think company
man did a video about that
yeah yeah well he did a company he did a
video about chiquita
yeah and he talked a little bit about oh
yeah well there a lot of that happened
and we did weird things to brazil well
those countries all know about it
but it's not taught here in the united
states like uh
american banks basically raped brazil
consistently since the 1950s
you know what they did to them is
[ __ ] they actually crushed brazil
[ __ ]
five or six times so a lot of the chaos
you see in brazil
actually was because of new york baggers
mango said never tried squirrel what's
it taste like squirrel tastes kind of
like
dark meat chicken except the pieces are
smaller
yeah kinda yeah or kind of like
rabbit but it's a little more tender
because the the fibers are smaller
it you kind of feel like a murderer i
went out there and [ __ ] shot up a
whole bunch of them to make a stew
and when i got done i was sticking them
through my belt look i had a damn
[ __ ] first girl skirt
[Laughter]
came back home you know my destiny dad
look at that squirrel i got man that's
good we have a feast and he's
chuckling he goes man that won't fill
that won't fill either one of us
and i said look at all these squirrels
man this is 20 30 squirrels because
you'll see
so clean like a little squirrel
apocalypse yeah squirrel apocalypse
and then [ __ ] ended up with two piles
a big old pile of
squirrel trimmings and fur and [ __ ] on
one side and guts
and a little bitty pile of little naked
men on the other one i'm going man
that's all it is because yeah now watch
when you boil them and all the meat
falls off
so you boil boil them in a stew and all
the meat falls off you gotta get the
bones out of there because the bones are
tidy
and then uh once you separate the meat
from the bones then you can take the
broth and the
the meat and pour that into an into the
pot where you had your
vegetable stock going so you kind of you
know you're trying you got to separate
the bottles
they're little and uh you realize that
really all that made was about it
it must been 20 of them and and it was
kind of like it made the equivalent of
like two beef patties
that's how it hardly seems worth it yeah
that's not a mountain
their tiny little squirrel children yeah
back in the day it was like
it was a massacre well you could kill
one rabbit you could kill one rabbit and
get more meat than that
yeah i mean rabbits aren't big either
but they have like a lot more meat on
them yeah and you don't have to kill
what
yeah i'm out there just damn just
[ __ ]
slaughter apocalypse on these [ __ ]
squirrels they're going no
and they're [ __ ] trying to get away
from you you have to shoot them three
times with 22
because the [ __ ] 22 rounds just blow
right through them doesn't do a lot of
damage
just kind of pierces them see it's got
to be a head shot
funny man they'd be shot up jumping from
limb to limb with [ __ ] one leg
dangling and shot the pieces and [ __ ]
and then by the time he falls out of the
tree he's just [ __ ] all shot up
squirrels are hardcore he's looking at
you like no don't do it like why did you
do this to me
yeah yeah yeah yes i felt bad about you
[ __ ] you're so much bigger
they're little you know and and and
little creatures don't apply any
resistance to a bullet as it passes
through them yeah
none of it's none of it is kind of none
of it is transmitted into them
yeah a pellet rifle
has a lot less energy and it smacks them
a lot harder because it has less energy
so there's like more resistance and it
seemed to kill him a lot better
yeah because his shit's just going to go
through him and he's going to keep
running around
yeah didn't do much damage to him do you
remember when we were walking on the
trail one
afternoon and we found that little
squirrel that he had either
fallen really far out of a tree or he'd
been hit by a bicycle
i'm not really sure i think he did too
he didn't look all [ __ ] up or anything
we brought him back to the house yeah i
tried to bring back try to bring him
back to life
pookie was super excited and she was
like what you got there what you got
there
we had well we had to like take him in
this bathroom right here and close the
door because pookie kept like
yeah she was like yelling at the door
like let me in there let me i want to
eat it yeah he was alive yeah he was
still alive but he was unconscious
yeah and we tried to keep him like we
thought he might be okay but then we
we put him out in little blankets and
put him out in the garage but the next
day
he was just running in a circle every
now and then
yeah he but he never opened his eyes he
must have fallen off you know
yeah well doc we called dr matt dr
messes yeah they fall out of trees all
the time
and hit their heads on the way down and
uh
he says they they got little bitty
fragile skulls and yeah and
it swells up and they never make it he
says they never make it and the trail is
not dirt it's
paved i found him in a damn he was in
the ground [ __ ] head first in an ant
bed and the ants were eating
yes we were like yeah we can't leave yes
we started it's like he hadn't been
there long no
no he hadn't a few minutes okay i think
we found him on the way back so he must
have fallen out like when we
yeah it was like it was really sad we
were kind of hoping that he would
live but he didn't he lived through the
night and then he just died the next day
but you know all right you uh that's it
that's all you have anything else you
have
anybody has any um
like i said any other ideas about [ __ ]
you have in the pantry or whatever i
don't even remember what all's in there
there's so much crap in there
other than like canned beans and whatnot
we got a lot of dried beans and
pasta and [ __ ] yeah but yeah all right
so
um i guess either we'll do another show
like a food show tomorrow or we'll do a
movie show tomorrow we haven't really
decided we'll figure it out
uh but yeah so thanks everybody for
dropping by as usual
and um we'll be back again tomorrow at 3
p.m eastern standard time just like
regular
so we'll see you then